سيصبح الطقس سيئًا بحلول
الوقت الذي نصل فيه إلى الغد ،
تقول دائرة الأرصاد الجوية الوطنية أن هذا حدث مرة واحدة
في كل جيل ، لذا فهذه كلمات كبيرة
قادمة من خدمة الطقس ،
يتجه الثلج اليوم عبر
داكوتا الغربية ، مينيسوتا ، سنرى
الظروف الشبيهة بالعاصفة الثلجية على الأرجح
بحلول الوقت الذي نصل فيه إلى الغد ،
يمكن أن تمتد هذه الظروف حتى
مساء الخميس في شيكاغو حتى يوم الجمعة
وتنبيهات الطقس الشتوي تنبيهات الرياح الباردة التي
تمتد تقريبًا عبر كل ولاية
في أقل من 48. نحن نبحث في
احتمال قدم  من المحتمل أن تشهد الثلوج
عبر أجزاء الغرب الأوسط من ميشيغان
من 12 إلى 18 بوصة من الثلج من
الخميس إلى الجمعة ، لذا
سيكون السفر بمثابة كابوس في شيكاغو في
الساحل الشرقي سنرى
تأثيرًا مضاعفًا هناك أيضًا هطول أمطار غزيرة
عبر I-  95 Corridor ولكن
تنبيهات الرياح الباردة تمتد على طول
الطريق إلى جنوب تكساس ،
انظر فلوريدا بانهاندل إلى هذه الرياح الباردة 50
درجة تحت الصفر في كاس  في وايومنغ
، ستكون هذه درجات حرارة
لن ينسى الناس الأحجار الكريمة أبدًا